is it weird that only now after watching
this movie do I want to climb Mount
Everest I don't think this is supposed
to be like that I think I'm supposed to
be like oh never do that but I never lie
kind of want to do it
Everest
so Everest is a true story about an
expedition in the 90s that went up to
Mount Everest the highest peak on earth
it's a pretty dangerous place like it's
broken down in this movie the human
body's not meant to survive and live at
the cruising altitude of a 747 at a
point I think they call it the Death
Zone up Mount Everest your body
literally starts dying so you need to
get to the peak and get back down before
your body does what it is supposed to do
which is shut down and die there are a
lot of people going up this mountain a
lot of alpha personality is a storm
comes in and you'll a is the perfect
storm ultimately for bad things to
happen which also makes for you know
movies Jason Clark arguably is the main
actor in this movie he's not the biggest
actor in this movie but he is the main
actor he's a great actor that dude
delivers he proves that he should stick
around regardless of Terminator Genisys
that's not the biggest name we have in
this movie Josh Brolin's also in this
movie Jake Gyllenhaal's in this movie
this movie I love the way it's cast cuz
usually in a movie like this you're like
alright Mount Everest things might go
wrong right who's in this movie of that
person's the biggest actor in this movie
that means that person is safe they're
not going to die nothing bad will happen
to them now you have quite a few good
and big actors in this movie to where
you're like I don't know if anyone's
safe I can't actually pick apart who
might make it through this ordeal and I
love that the movie is
interestingly informative a movie like
this needs to be when they're breaking
it down you know like all the human body
is gonna break down at this point
between this point and this point so you
need oxygen tanks there you need to
climate eyes I was sitting there like
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah that's
important yeah yeah I'm glad you touched
on that I'm really glad we know now not
every movie can make information cool
but this movie made information cool and
most importantly this movie makes you
feel like you are with this crew as they
make their ascent up Mount Everest the
scenery the cinematography you're
looking around you're like whoa those
clouds down there those are the clouds
that I can look up and see are really
high they're really high clouds to the
rest of the world but not up here in
Mount Everest
you're high two times in life people
have been this high as they climb Mount
Everest and after weed was legalized in
Washington State there's the two times
there's teens were there on these
rickety ash ladders going across this
precipice it just goes down to darkness
doom and death and you're like I don't
want a beer
soundtrack was great too I love this
store the musical score in this movie I
was thinking I was I was watching I was
like it reminds me of the game braid and
then my friend and I were driving on my
friend was like soundtrack in that movie
reminded me of braid so it's apparently
official if you like the braid
soundtrack you'll like the music in this
movie this movie did have some pacing
issues but I mean by that is ultimately
time is kind of going linear and then
there are moments where it's like
goodness it just speeds up where you're
like oh five minutes two days went by it
was kind of jarring it's like did we hit
a montage did I blink and miss it bummer
is it's when these emotional moments
have to start happening and so it just
feels like the movies fast-forwarding
and when a movie fast forwards through
the emotional moments it really doesn't
land as much as it should that the movie
just cuts off and ends abruptly I was
like yeah we have another 20 minutes of
old credits all right I guess guys in
the end Everest is a grand spectacle if
you've ever wanted to hike Mount Everest
but you didn't want you know your dick
to freeze and snap off perfect thing for
you you can now watch it in a movie
theater at room temperature I love the
actors in the movie they did a good job
in this movie the movie has glaring
pacing issues I think you're like
sometimes the movie speeds up when it
shouldn't have sped up and it slows down
when it should have sped up but in the
end I will say Everest is a good time no
alcohol required right guys so Everest
have you seen it what did you think
about it and want to climb Mount Everest
now come on you know you do frostbite
Schmauss bite let's do it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you